- So, how's the family doing, though?
What do y'all do for Christmas?
- They're doing great.
Well, actually, Michael has been in France
for what seems like a lifetime,
shooting a really great project.
But being over there.
So the kids and I actually
surprised him for Thanksgiving.
He had no idea.
- Oh, that's cool.
- And Carys, my daughter,
flew from the East Coast.
I was here with my son.
We flew here, got into the
hotel under the cover of night.
He came home from work and there we were.
It was one of those,
I thought he was gonna have a
heart attack for one minute.
(audience laughs)
- [Catherine] He kind of
stumbled back and went,
"Oh my God," and started crying.
- Aw.
- It was one of those
great, great, great moments.
- Oh, I love that. I love a good surprise.